we were told not to raise our hands
because snipers on the other side can
see us and
then shoot i'm here in the trenches
between the ukraine control territories
of the east
and the donetsk separatist republic
which is backed by russia
the fighting in eastern ukraine between
the kiev government forces
and the separatists escalated since late
march
it's the only active armed conflict in
europe at the moment
and this is all happening as russia
built up a large military presence in
two places on the eastern border with
ukraine
and in crimea which russia seized from
ukraine in 2014.
these events are not only testing
ukraine's government but also sending a
message to its ally
the us and the new by the administration
here the war has been going on for seven
years now
there was just a lot of explosion on the
other side
soldiers here used to that some of them
not even flinch when they hear that the
ceasefire which was agreed last july and
was
initially holding really well has been
breached repeatedly this year
both sides have been accusing each other
of
breaching that ceasefire the increase
in ceasefire violations and the russian
troop amassement
they happened at the same time western
officials have said that
russia had stationed up to 100 000
troops along the border
and the view from kiev is that this was
pushed by moscow so to escalate the
situation on the ground here
russia has on the other hand accused
ukraine of escalating the situation
now the question of course is what the
kremlin stands to gain
from this show of power along the border
part of it is signaling
that russia has the military power and
presence
and if they choose they could escalate
the military
situation in ukraine i spoke with
president putin of russia
and since we have a new u.s
administration the kremlin
has been looking at ways to test biden's
government
and to signal that russia cannot be
swayed and cannot be hampered by
sanctions or
western pressure president biden
president putin will likely
meet for a summit this summer and until
then
it's a matter of raising the stakes for
russia
but in any case the withdrawal of forces
while
it has been welcomed by ukraine and the
west as a way to de-escalate the
situation
it is by no means clear how many russian
troops
and equipment will stay and where so the
situation continues
to be quite volatile people here
soldiers they say they're ready they
said they're ready for
new escalation in fire and that happens
they say they will
defend their country for them it's
really looking over the trenches
and paying attention to snipers to
mortar fire
shelling that's the daily concern
some of them say that it's really for
politicians
to find ways to achieve peace